I think we'll start
we're taping this welcome to the
Macmillan Center
and not Ian Shapiro Ian is tied up this
afternoon and graciously asked me if I
might substitute for him my name is Jim
Levinson I'm the director of the Jackson
Institute we're delighted to host Ann
Marie slaughter as the Henry L Stimson
lecturer and Marie slaughter is the
president and CEO of New America from
2009 through 2011 she served as director
of policy planning for the u.s.
Department of State the first woman to
hold that position prior to her
government service professor slaughter
was Dean of the Woodrow Wilson School
that's
Princeton's version of the Jackson
Institute if you haven't heard of it and
before that she was a professor at
Harvard Law School
she's written a number of books many of
you will know her from her 2012 article
in the Atlantic when she published why
women still can't have it all an article
which quickly became the most read
article in the history of the magazine
and helped spark a national debate
professor slaughter is giving three
lectures this afternoon is the second of
those sponsored by the Macmillan Center
and the Yale University Press the
funding for the lecture series comes
from an anonymous donor in honor of
Henry L Stimson Yale class of 1889 an
attorney and statesman and someone whose
government service culminated as a stint
as the war secretary during World War
two previous stinson lectures lecturers
have included Samuel Huntington Tom
shellene ambassador Marwan Maurer sure
David Mayhew and John Donne I'm pleased
to introduce anne-marie slaughter it's
all yours
thank you I do like being in the same
series as John Donne it's probably a
different John Donne that I'm thinking
of imagine that no man is an island here
we go
so well I'm delighted to be back
yesterday I talked about the chessboard
and the web and I offered two
complementary perspectives on the
international system the chessboard view
which is the traditional geopolitical
view focusing on States focusing on a
world mostly of competition or conflict
and thinking through strategies
essentially in terms of games not just
chess but chicken or poker growing
chickens just bluffing of various kinds
or stag hunt or prisoner's dilemma and I
art then said that optic is does
describe a very important part of the
international system but it must be
complemented with the web perspective
and the web is not a spider's web it is
a web like the Internet a intersection
of networks of people of institutions of
companies and of criminals and we need
to see all issues in terms of both
optics we have a set of strategies for
the chessboard world we don't have a set
of strategies for the web world so the
reason you we want to use the web
perspective is it shows you things you
don't see when you look through the
lenses of the chessboard it gives you
tools to address a set of 21st century
web problems though all of what we would
call the transnational problems from
pandemics to climate change to terrorist
networks and it gives you a set of tools
to address the existing problems in ways
that we again don't think of so if
you're looking at something like Iran or
Ukraine we can sanction weak and we can
threaten we can actually use force
there are they're a whole other set of
strategies but they involve the
deliberate and careful construction of
networks so today that's what we're
doing this is really the meat of this
project today and I have never attempted
to do what I'm about to do before in the
sense that I have said for many years
that you should be able to take network
theory and apply it to develop distinct
categories of networks and distinct
strategies within those categories just
as Thomas Schelling in the strategy of
conflict used game theory to develop a
set of categories for a world of
conflict so the title today is Network
strategies for resilience action and
scale and we're gonna go through those
categories and I'm gonna draw on
research about network structures and
properties to show you how we can take
different types of networks to address
different kinds of foreign policy
problems that's not the real here we go
let's try this one okay so you're gonna
see this slide a lot so don't don't try
to write it down I'm gonna keep coming
back to it to keep you oriented because
we're marching through nine
subcategories so we're going to as I do
this I my method is neither wholly
deductive nor wholly inductive I'm gonna
move back and forth between theory and
empirical examples of networks that
actually are working and what I'm trying
to do is to provide a basic typology
that matches up categories of problems
with categories of networks if I succeed
I would imagine in five to ten years
this will look very primitive this will
seem like a very very basic typology
absolutely but we're bushwhacking where
we're really headed we're not heading
into new territory for people in other
disciplines but we are in foreign policy
and when I just when I talk about
network theory I'm referring to many
different bodies of work
the common element is what
mathematicians would call graph theory
we
means the rendering of any phenomenon as
a collection of nodes and links or
mathematicians would call them edges so
we have mathematicians working it we've
done the sort of foundational work in
this area physicists biologists computer
scientists economists sociologists
technologists geographers organization
theorists and other disciplines have
contributed to network theory some of
these disciplines work out the formal
mathematical and physical properties of
networks and I will be very candid and
say I do cannot follow the mathematics
with which they do that others use
agent-based modeling using computer
simulations and still others the
sociologists begin with observations of
actual complex human networks it's no
accident than one of the most prominent
researchers in this field Duncan Watts
combines physics and sociology and
researchers in those disciplines use
network theory to describe and predict
the world of complex systems if those of
you who read work on complexity theory
and emergence indeed the pure network
theory is often intersects the fields of
complexity complex systems it's
impossible even if I had 20 lectures to
do justice to all of those strands of
scholarship I will do much more in the
book my job here is to simplify and to
stylize so we're gonna start with
resilience networks first category of
networks so in in our world where we're
facing increasing natural disasters
caused by climate change from hurricanes
to floods to droughts resilience has
been very much in vogue evolutionary
biologist Simon Levin and marine
ecologist Jane Lubchenco define
ecosystem resilience as quote as having
quote two key aspects resistance to
change as well as flexibility the amount
a system can be perturbed from its
reference state without that change
being essentially irreversible that's
the first aspect and more generally the
ability of the
them to recover so resistance to change
and the ability to recover in foreign
policy terms resilience building
resilience is often the same set of
activities necessary to do what we call
building government capacity in a
particular area that means strengthening
a government's ability to administer a
region from collecting taxes to
delivering services will also enhance
that government's ability to withstand
popular protest or external efforts to
destabilize it resilience can also be a
function of preventive efforts before a
crisis happens or responsive efforts
after it is hit so let's talk about the
structure of these networks in 1964 a
researcher at the RAND Corporation named
Paul Baran was asked to design a
communication system for the US
government that would be able to
withstand a nuclear attack was quite
relevant in 1964 as network theorist
alberto laszlo barabasi tells the story
bran baron came up with three possible
architectures and we saw this slide
yesterday but we're gonna see a lot
today centralized decentralized and
distributed he argued that only
distributed mesh networks could actually
survive a nuclear attack because it's
the only structure that doesn't have a
center that can be taken out so you know
even if you took out 3/4 of it or for
this-- of it there would be something
left he was ignored but ultimately the
the wires and the routers and the
servers that we now call the internet
did in fact evolve as a mesh network so
that is the the structure of the
internet so for our purposes I want to
call this the star it's a star it's
pretty a star a phone tree although I
realize I'm not sure how many younger
people even know what a phone tree is
anymore but hey never mind and then just
look at the structure of the of the
network one center and then lots of sub
centers and each of those sub centers
has the the in the phone tree the the
the school called you and you had to
call five neighbors and the
olden days and then a a distributed
network which I think of as the hammock
just for poor so each of those each of
these structures is useful in thinking
about different kinds of resilience
networks and we're gonna begin with a
basic structure of how different nodes
should be connected and then equally
importantly is actually whom we are
connecting and we'll talk about the how
and the who as we go through so the the
first subcategory of our resilience
networks are defence networks so the
three sub categories so that now we go
back to Ukraine we talked about Ukraine
a lot yesterday so Russia is accused of
perpetrating a new form of hybrid
warfare which means infiltrating
soldiers who cannot be identified as
Russian troops but who fight on the side
of Ukrainian separatists Russian tactics
actually in Syria are similar Vladimir
Putin announced that 10,000 Russian
volunteers we're heading to Syria to
support Bashar al-assad's government in
Syria's Civil War we know they're
Russian troops but there's plausible
deniability or implausible deniability
so war is actually a chessboard issue
normally but fighting terrorist networks
and other non-state actors and indeed
for these purposes Russian troops are
non-state actors because they're not
identified as Russian troops requires
the national security establishment to
think in network terms how do we build a
defense network that will be resilient
against persistent armed destabilization
exactly what's happening in these in
eastern Ukraine alternatively think
about the need to build defense networks
or defensive networks I call them
defense networks against the spread of
pandemics either actual or viral
computer viruses spread much the same
way that biological viruses do and in
both cases the kind of robustness the
kind of connectivity that creates
robustness in some areas also creates an
Achilles heel that can bring down an
entire network and I'm going to explain
so health systems and let me
Health Systems we go to the next slide
here right alright so health systems and
the Internet are both scale-free
networks that are characterized not by a
rising symmetry of connections the kind
of bells bell curve where you sort of
most of the connections are at the top
of the curve and then you start low in
you and low but in but rather in a
pattern of relatively few major nodes or
hubs and thousands of millions of
smaller nodes so this is again I'm
relying on barabasi but if you want to
think about a bell curve distribution
you'd look at this is interstate
highways across the u.s. roughly every
hub every hub has roughly the same
number of links right it's kind of a
nice proportional that every every place
looks pretty much the same the
scale-free network looks much more like
the airline network you have some hubs
that have a large number indeed that's
what we call hubs we have a large number
of links and then you have lots of
smaller airports that have almost no
links at all
as many of us know if we don't live near
a hub so the this structure is very
robust against random failures in any
part of the system because it's almost
always possible to find another route to
the destination so if a road is blocked
to one city in the region then our
clinic is closed in one village or a
town or one router goes down then
another road or clinic or electronic
circuit will be available and will be
connected to through a hub or a city or
a portal on the other hand in this kind
of a structure if you take out if you so
responsiveness to error it's very robust
because error just happens randomly if
you are subject to an attack and you
take out the deliberate attacks against
major hubs you can bring down the entire
system quite quickly so it's the very
same structure that makes it real
bust against error makes it vulnerable
against attack that means a true
defensive Network not just a robust
network but a defensive at net whoops
network would go back actually to the
hammock that actually what you need is a
distributed network you really need
something that where you could take out
all of those herbs and you still have or
almost all and you still have a a few
left so you think well that's great but
that that may be cold comfort in eastern
Ukraine because you've already got a
network of towns and cities and villages
and it's grown up over centuries and
warfare has always been about capturing
major hubs that's you know the goal is
to capture the other side's hubs but to
prepare for hybrid warfare in which
armies no longer march across borders
but instead infiltrate bands of Special
Forces into neighboring territory
resilience requires altering the objects
of their attack rather than countering
them directly transportation
manufacturing and garrison networks must
be distributed as evenly and as widely
as possible with air strips and bases
down scaled and spaced apart all right
that may sound crazy but if you're in
California and you're talking about the
future of work what you are hearing is
that actually knowledge industries are
heading in that direction in and in
workers can be located wherever their
computers are often in small clusters
but without the need for large central
headquarters and in my other life on
work and family this is a great thing
but we're going to leave that apart so
the digit and similarly if you look at
the future of manufacturing and you talk
to the people who really are do it
looking at digital manufacturing not
just 3d printing but across the board
they will tell you the same thing we're
going to be able to make what we need
wherever we are we're effectively
heading back to a world of cottage
industry just very sophisticated cut the
cottage industry so Ukraine can't
dismantle its existing cities in border
areas but it can create a distributed
transport military and man
you're factoring that then it can be
laid over its existing grid hybrid
enemies will then be in a situation
where they can take over small nodes but
never capture the prize that assures
them victory in a particular region or
sub region the same strategy applies to
viruses so a typical Health System
radiates outward from major hospitals to
smaller hospitals to clinics even think
think about New Haven and from the Yale
hospital much like an airline routing
system that system works fine in normal
times it ensures both broad access for a
population and the development of
specialized medical expertise that is
only practicable in a large teaching
hospital but they the Achilles heel of
that system once again is evident the
minute a deadly virus like Ebola is
introduced the big Hospital hubs become
the transmission points exactly as big
city airports to so effective defense
against a pandemic requires creating a
distributed network again the hammock a
fully distributed network of clinics and
hospitals that are specifically designed
for fighting infectious diseases that
can be transmitted from human to human
via bodily fluids or an aerosol form
it's essential to separate infectious
patients from other patients so
specialized facilities can also stock
the protective equipment that is
necessary even within cities infectious
disease hospitals and clinics can be
separated from other hospitals either is
completely separate wings complete with
their own emergency facilities or a
separate establishments so again and we
already have a hospital system
constructing a parallel distributed
Health System may seem impossible or at
least impossibly expensive but if you
actually think that pandemics are one of
our gravest security challenges I mean
you look at Ebola and all you had to
think was this is the virus that is
suddenly transmitted in aerosol form I
spend my life on airplanes you stop
getting on a plane instantly right in it
not only is there the danger of millions
of deaths but well short of that you
close
mortars we saw that right you closed
borders the economy goes down so this is
as grave a national security threat
frankly as nuclear the risk of nuclear
war was and it's precisely because it's
so grave a threat because the world has
become an interlocking set of networks
that are connected by a perilously small
number of major hubs the great strength
of the very system that we have for
spreading knowledge and economic growth
and positive innovation is also its
greatest weakness just as a building has
a backup electrical system for when
disaster strikes
so most cities regions and nations
develop backup systems to build the
resilience we need and those systems
have to take very different Network
forms all right that's okay so now that
was defense networks so let's move on to
response networks still in the category
of resilience and indeed resilience as I
said is a is as much about rapid and
effective response as it is about
preparation and the indeed creating
distributed defence networks is itself a
response to anticipated dangers parallel
networks that can be activated when the
threat materializes but in the moment of
actual crisis particularly a hurricane
an earthquake a localized crisis
immediate response networks are equally
essential to minimizing the loss of life
and providing assistance to those in
need the most immediate need in a
natural disaster or an attack like 9/11
or sadly Paris last week is for
information for citizens inside and
outside the strike zone those in
wondering where to go those outside
wondering what's happened for first
responders for government officials and
for disaster assistance organizations a
speedy accurate and effective
information network requires a
combination of scouts aggregators and
curators Scouts are on the ground there
essentially anyone with a cell phone and
an SMS code aggregators of the people
and the machines that
can assemble streams of information from
multiple sources and map the integrated
content in real-time their filtering for
accuracy in the process they take
crowd-sourced information and they layer
reports on top of each other to create a
topography of the disaster so if one
report of a fire or a collapsed building
or a washed out bridge comes in
it may be suspect particularly in the
face of a conflicting report and believe
me having done this on Twitter in the
midst of crisis this happens all the
time so one may be suspect but if 10
reports come in particularly if they
have pictures then you get an accurate
map and so those are the aggregators who
are assembling the information curators
are the people who then determine what
information should be disseminated back
out to responders victims families and
the public at large
they must be personnel experience both
in disaster response and the kinds of
curation tools that are afforded by new
types of media based on social media
something like Storify are now twitter
moments a critical sense ability to sift
out hyperbole and a healthy skepticism
that insists on multiple sources is
essential really journalists training as
well as information of what kind of
information different audiences need and
how to present that and the best form to
present that information none of that
sounds like a typical government job
description even for something like the
Federal Emergency Management it says
agency employees but those are functions
that are essential in a crisis the
structure of that kind of a network has
to include many tiny nodes who will
serve there the initial Scouts right so
you spread out all the way to as many
people who are on the ground but it must
also have one central node one
clearinghouse for all the information
received a simple star model however
will be too inefficient so if we go back
to this you can't have a network I mean
you have lots and lots of Scouts but if
you just have one Center it's going to
be inefficient think about 911 or even
this weekend but think about nine
where we had attacks in four three
different places and one possible fourth
so imagine if all information about the
attacks in New York had had to be routed
through a central command that was in DC
New York needed its own central command
center and indeed within New York
different fire houses and police
precincts were also command centers for
what was coming in so what we then need
is a modified phone tree which is known
as a modular hierarchical Network so
this is what it looks like
so in a modular hierarchical Network you
have you do have one big central node
right that central one is connected to
everybody else and it but then each so
that central node is connected to other
central nodes in a descending hierarchy
of centrality and connectedness so out
here right you're connected to only a
few as you go in you're connected to
more and at the very center you're
connected to everyone each central node
is not only connected to all the other
nodes in the district but they are all
connected to each other that degree of
information means that information flows
to everyone in the sub Network in real
time allowing somebody in a collapsed
building to communicate immediately not
only to disaster central but also to the
nearest firehouse or police car or
neighbor with a shovel or a truck at the
same time that information is flowing to
a local set of aggregators and curators
who can assemble map and filter it
before sending it up the chain the next
question for a response network is whom
to connect so these are just random dots
but obviously they wouldn't be if we
were designing these networks it's been
repeatedly demonstrated in actual crises
and most recently after the earthquake
in Haiti and I wish I had the time to go
through that but we don't that responses
are much more effective when government
coordinates closely with
non-governmental crisis organizations
like Doctors Without Borders or care or
Oxfam many others equally businesses
with global and local supply chains have
vital networks and material to offer if
you remember after Katrina Walmart was
doing better than FEMA technology
companies such as Google and Twitter and
played essential roles in the Haiti
earthquake and also Japan's triple
earthquake tsunami and Radiological
disaster serving as emergency
communications and query systems and
creating tools such as Google's people
finder so if you take account of those
lessons crisis planners should be
creating a hierarchical modular network
that connects key connectors those sub
nodes from government NGOs and business
within each central node they should
prepare and publicize key disaster
responses response texts numbers like
911 our three one for normal disasters
so citizens know where to send
information in extraordinary
circumstances at the same time personnel
within central nodes must be prepared to
curate information from curate
information from and distribute
information to social media channels
radio broadcasters and good
old-fashioned television and regional
news media the structure of the network
and the players can be identified in
advance but planners have to of course
expect the fluidity and the flux of an
actual disaster and be able to be
prepared to call information from every
conceivable source so that model of
networks this looks very nice and neat
and you're probably thinking yeah in a
write after a building collapses after a
hurricane you know how on earth are we
gonna have something this tidy
understood but details preparation in
terms of figuring out who should be
connected and how on the day will save
lives and it will also calm panic just
like fire drill
preparing to allow people to connect to
one another can actually be particularly
important community members
traditionally weave their own webs of
resilience somebody emerges as a focal
point and an information source using
network theory to design response
networks allows communities to do what
they want to do naturally while also
funneling information to and from the
responders
who need the responders who need it and
all the citizens who want to help okay
back to this back to the slide we've
done defense networks response networks
and I want to talk about stabilization
networks and this is a we're gonna go
back to Ukraine again so we I said
yesterday that Ukraine needs a set of
stabilization and assistance networks
for the Ukrainian government just like
the networks that the Europe and the
United States put in place in Eastern
and Central Europe after the fall of the
wall so stabilize and today we're gonna
we're gonna get into the actual
structure of those networks stabilizing
and strengthening a new or fragile
government is just another form of
building resilience as I said we call it
capacity building but it's giving if
giving a government the capacity to
withstand and respond many of the most
dangerous foreign policy threats we face
arise from the inability of weak
governments to actually to provide
security health care education
opportunity for their citizens the
allowing crime and corruption terrorism
environmental degradation poverty
disease and conflict to grow and spread
effective stabilization and response
networks are thus a form of that much
maligned term State Building the problem
is that we typically focus much more on
the actual assistance that we are
providing and much less on the
relationships that we are building so we
think about state building it's all
about well what what do they need and
less about how are we actually building
those critical relationships what
matters most is a mesh and meshing
judges legislators and executive
officials in peer groups who can both
support Ana system but also raise
standards about professional behavior
the best structure for these networks is
once again told you we're going to see
these two slides quite a bit but we'll
see other ones too is once again a
modified phone tree but this time with a
much simpler modification than the
modular hierarchic modular hierarchy
Cerie for effective response networks
it's simply necessary to make sure that
the these nodes are actually what I
think of as pods that they are all
connected so if you think about networks
that would connect judges or legislators
or executive members of executives and
you have a center for each one of those
networks what you have to make sure is
that this what looks like a network
where everybody's connected to the
center that they are all connected to
each other it's it's the density and the
vibrancy of those connections that can
make the difference as well as they're
linked back to a larger network so
what's going on there the power of
stabilization and assistance and
resilience in those networks is the
power of human connection as we'll
discuss tomorrow
traditional conceptions of power assume
some kind of action generally of either
coercion or the threat of coercion to
compel people to do something they don't
otherwise want to do
that's definitely generally the
traditional definition of power
josè Joseph Nye talks about soft power
which substitutes the power of
attraction which is a positive rather
than negative force and there's no
question that part of what is operating
here is a kind of soft power but I want
to argue that power in networks in fully
connected groups or clubs at some point
then when they're fully connected we
couldn't think of as a club is simpler
still it's the power of recognition it's
rooted in the fundamental human desire
to be connected to others and actually
to be seen and recognized by those
others as a peer it's interesting to be
talking about this at Yale right now
this is the it's relevant to the
disturbances because it is a desire to
be seen to be heard to be recognized to
be recognized as an equal or having your
concerns be recognized as equally
important it's also a desire that both
philosophers and evolutionary biologists
have identified as essential
to who we are as human beings to the
evolution of our society so the
traditional conception of building
capacity and fragile governments focuses
on assistance on the transfer of
knowledge and skills necessary to carry
out a specific administrative tasks and
a set of professional standards aimed at
combating corruption the network concept
focuses on the value of connection
itself on building a circle of ongoing
relationships that can both create a
sense of belonging and X and exert peer
pressure as Tina Rosenberg describes
enjoying the club the creation of peer
groups has spread revolution taught high
school kids algebra and sharply the
reduce the incidence of AIDS in South
Africa and I can't tell you more than
you've got to read the book but she
documents exactly as I said yesterday
any parent of teenagers understands the
power of peer pressure this is
essentially positive peer pressure so
structure is part of this equation the
basic phone tree is modified to create
links between all the nodes in a pod so
that it becomes a fully integrated sub
Network so imagine for instance the
Ukrainian new Ukrainian finance minister
and her top officials are integrated
into a pod network of 10 or so EU
finance ministers a u.s. deputy or
Undersecretary of the Treasury and
perhaps a Canadian Japanese or
Australian member member the Ukrainian
justice minister would be part of a
similarly curated network of justice
ministers they would be all connected to
each other and would meet on the side of
global and regional meetings twice or
three times a year tomorrow I'm going to
talk about what it's necessary to make
those networks thrive you can create
those groups nothing's going to happen
there's a particular kind of leadership
and management that we'll talk about so
thus far we've been talking about
government to government networks
equally important our people-to-people
networks that government can facilitate
so the State Department launched
something called the Global
Entrepreneurship program that was
designed to identify and train and
connect promising entrepreneurs in
countries in the Middle East and beyond
and connect them to each other and to
financing networks but mentors market
access context
and ongoing support networks with the
idea of creating an entrepreneurial
ecosystem on the Silicon Valley model it
got off to a very promising start in
Egypt and North Africa but it was never
fully funded or embraced by traditional
diplomats who are thinking in the
chessboard world not in the web world if
we really want to help you young
Ukrainians imagine a different future we
need to be enabling as many of them as
possible to innovate and create jobs for
one another we also then have to build a
web that connects them to knowledge and
opportunity so a web with many strong
and central nodes is both stable and
vibrant instead of trying to build a
nation think of supporting and
strengthening people who want to build
their own nation and creating a culture
and peers that reinforce their best
instincts in the face of flagging will
and periodic despair think of it as work
that takes just as much energy and skill
as negotiating a peace agreement or
assembling a coalition of nations to
pursue a common policy of coercion or
attraction alright let's move to our
second category of networks let me see
how we're doing here so I mentioned this
yesterday our second category our task
networks the goal of resilience networks
are to strengthen deepen react respond
bounce back stabilize and assist all
dimensions of resilience task networks
surprise surprise are networks that are
created to perform more precise and
time-bound tasks like resilience
networks these networks can have
different structures and properties such
as the degree of integration and the
nature of clustering I should say here
and I'd go into much greater length than
you know in the book terminology here
can be tricky a many theorists don't
distinguish between cooperation and
collaboration and use the terms
interchangeably and they're not mutually
exclusive categories and creating this
kind of a typology they're rarely
mutually exclusive you'll be able to say
well wait a minute you said that's a
cooperation network and it's got
collaboration and it yes but bear with
me
meaningful distinctions are possible
they depend in the way I'm going to lay
this
on the initial preferences of the
individuals and the groups involved it's
possibly possible to design a network
primarily for cooperation collaboration
or innovation even if it has other
properties as well and I differentiate
among the three based on the level of
precision of the task that's assigned
all right so a cooperation network is a
linked group of individuals working
together to carry out a prescribed task
in a prescribed way a collaboration
network is a linked group of individuals
figuring out together
the best ways to carry out a prescribed
task that itself may evolve so certainly
the way you carried out evolves and
frankly over collaboration the task
itself becomes clearer and changes an
innovation network is a linked group of
individuals tasked with generating new
ideas processes and/or products in the
service of a prescribed general goals so
there is still a goal it's still a task
network it's not just building
resilience I mean you could say building
resilience is a task but that is so
broad here you you have a goal but it's
more general and the whole point is to
come up with new ways to do it so the
classic cooperation problem in
international relations scholarship is
the prisoner's dilemma and the classic
strategy to turn conflicting incentives
into cooperative behavior as I mentioned
yesterday is Robert Axelrod stip for tat
each player's best strategy from an
individual perspective is to defect but
if they all pursue that strategy they
will all get the suckers they will all
be worse off than if they cooperate such
a strategy works well enough in a game
with limited players certainly during
the US and the Soviet Union and/or today
the United States and China or the
United States I don't mean to analogize
China the Soviet Union it's not but in
certain circumstances but then how to
adapt that strategy to the web world
with a potentially unlimited number of
players and I know there's been
extensive work done on end player game
theory I still I'm going to I'm going to
assert that none of that actually gets
to the the sheer
number of players that you would have
when you're talking about the web world
and in theory it's everybody in the
world the prisoner's dilemma in turn is
just one of the category of collection
active collective action problems in
which private incentives conflict with
the provision of a public good so the
classic formulation of that problem as I
think you probably all know is the
tragedy of the Commons where sheep
owners know they all need the common
grazing space but to keep it they can't
all graze at the same time so they have
to find a way obviously to rotate and
unless you find a way to actually
cooperate on a rotating basis
no one has an incentive to refrain and
of course you you lose the Commons
that's the classic chessboard way of
looking at these problems can now let's
think about the web perspective and
let's think about a problems such as the
conflict between China and its neighbors
in the East and South China Seas or
between Iran and its neighbors in the
Middle East and Southwest Asia or
between Venezuela and its neighbors and
the Caribbean all of those situations
present the age-old problem of how to
diminish the risk of outright conflict
by building cooperation among people and
institutions in these societies even in
the face of government hostility and
rising tensions and just think in the
Middle East how often you hear people
say we don't hate the American people we
admire the American people we hate the
government and you think well you know
if you could just build that strong
networks of cooperation you'd have some
counterbalance but how do you do that
when the government is demonized each
government is demonizing the other so
the classic and weak answer to that
question has been to foster exchanges of
students museum exhibits dance companies
and research teams in areas that are
research teams in areas that are far
from national security those exchanges
have indeed yielded valuable
relationships but on a fairly random
basis in a way that's hard to track or
use in times of crisis actually the best
ones are scientific networks the Pugwash
networks they are terrific they can be
activated and sometimes have been but
again that's not a foreign policy maker
thinking about that it's a foreign
policy maker should be thinking about
that and should be thinking about how to
actually enable private actors to do it
so suppose we could actually build
durable and spreading networks of
cooperation by connecting the right
people in the right way so take what
we're already doing but doing it do it
in a much more deliberate fashion so
Studies on repeated games the kinds of
games from which tit-for-tat
arises have demonstrated that if the
principal players come to know and
engage each other so not just the
tit-for-tat knowing but the really
knowing each other they become much more
patient and likely to sustain
cooperation over time and the structure
of the networks that breed that type of
cooperation look like this so this is a
the networks that are that endure for
cooperation have a core of players who
are all connected to each other and
connected to each other over time they
actually build trust and relationships
and they are then connected to various
other players and over time those other
some of those other players actually
also cooperate so the cooperation does
spread but it's critical to have this
Center each member as so each member of
the the I just said that okay so what's
particularly interesting and I'm
fortunately I don't have time to go into
all of this is this works much better
than actually connecting all the outside
nodes to everyone I say some people know
that if you connect everyone what
actually happens is that cooperative
behavior immediately gets challenged by
non cooperative behavior and the non
cooperative behavior is more likely to
spread through the whole network so you
don't want a complete network you want a
network of a very concentrated core that
deepens cooperation and you want them to
be connected to other other members of
the broader network so if you translate
that into the foreign policy context
that finding suggests that among
populations who are naturally suspicious
of one another dude our historical
enmities and hostile governments it
should be pal
possible to build lasting channels of
transnational cooperation in different
sectors if you created a joint business
roundtable of Chinese and Japanese
business leaders for instance or an
educational Council of Chinese and
Japanese university presidents or an
environmental research partnership among
leading scientific researchers from both
countries that will have much more
impact if it's carefully designed and
supported as a foreign policy initiative
now again the government does not have
to convene or the government can't ask
others with convening but you should
begin with a relatively small cluster of
members all of whom are actively
connected to one another and all of whom
are actively tasked with engaging in
behavior that will be mutually
beneficial only if everyone cooperates
so you could take business leaders and
ask them to develop a joint marketing
campaign to promote each other's
products or you could take university
leaders and task them with developing
joint fundraising appeals something that
I know is generally anathema to
university leaders and to development of
officers but the point is if you chose
the the core of those networks carefully
and you structure a way and a set of
tasks to build deep cooperation at the
core you are then more likely to get
spreading cooperation and durable
cooperation which is exactly what we're
seeking because you want to then be able
to tap those networks in times of crisis
but you also want them to act as counter
balances to to more hostile forces in
the society okay so this is just an
example actually I said it would be a
prime you don't want a complete network
a complete network is just where
everybody is connected to everyone else
okay so that's cooperation networks
let's talk about collaboration networks
and I know I'm speeding through but this
is this is the core work so
collaboration problems arise when a
group of individuals want to work
together to solve a problem or are
required to but can't work together
effectively enough to achieve their
objective so I mentioned a general
mcchrystal yesterday and his team of
teams approach he was the four-star
general who was in charge of the Joint
Special Operations Command in Iraq he
was he he was in in 2004 he was tasked
with finding and destroying al-qaeda in
Iraq and he faced a dilemma which is
described in the following graphic drawn
from his book that is what the special
forces were designed to do and the
special forces are regarded as nimble in
the military this is as nimble as it
gets but it's still deeply hierarchical
that's what they were facing
that's what al Qaeda in Iraq looked like
so it you know al Qaeda
it's fascinating he opens the book with
the description of what you think is a
description of the how the Special
Forces operate and at the end of the
first chapter he says that's al Qaeda
that the sort of immediate adaptation to
what's going on the the communication
the finding the target that a changing
of plans so al Qaeda of course is a
network of many different individuals
and groups who execute attacks against a
wide variety of targets those attacks
are both centrally directed and carried
out autonomously by individual cells and
that that problems becoming even more
complicated now with Isis and there's
some centrally directed attacks and of
course there's some that are not so
McChrystal had to create matching
capabilities in his own organization to
transform his Special Forces operators
and that's what they're called from a
command a hierarchical command into a
team he had to build trust
quite I'm quoting him trust and a shared
sense of purpose consciously building
and deepening relationships among small
groups of people enough let them act
quote as a seamless unit even in
changing circumstances exercising quote
joint cognition so you practically
essentially had to weld them into one at
the same time team members could act as
individual units interacting continually
in unexpected and unpredictable ways
allowing the emergence of quote
ingenious solutions in the absence of
any
designer the combination McChrystal and
his co-authors argue he's a network
capable of solving large complex
problems relying on quote both the
visible hand of management and the
invisible hand of emergence so that some
kind of centrally directed management
but also that bottom-up magical
emergence of solutions the former the
management leaving the elements together
and the latter emergence guiding their
work so the structure of a team as he
defines it
he's an inter licked linked star so what
he's describing here is you've got to be
able to centrally direct all of these
people there's you know everyone that
has one mission and they're there teams
all over but there are the the the other
nodes are connected to each other right
so that's that he doesn't use that
terminology I'm using that terminology
but that's what it looks like they've
got to be able to act as a team these
three but they also need to be connected
to him and you could you could play that
play that out at the same time as I said
so those other nodes are connected to
each other in a way that allows for
decentralized intelligence to emerge but
he needed to go further than that he had
the the collaboration Network he had to
build had to rely on the coordinated and
cooperative activity of many teams but
if you linked everybody to each other if
you take this and imagine everyone being
linked to each other
you'd have too many links for efficiency
so as McChrystal put it quote we didn't
need everybody to follow every single
operation in real time we needed to
enable a team operating in an
interdependent environment to understand
the butterfly effect ramifications of
their work and to make them aware of the
other teams with whom they'd have to
cooperate in order to achieve strategic
success so you didn't want everybody
following everything else but you needed
enough awareness so people could adapt
and and respond and be aware so the
structure he came up with
had he been a network theorist is a
classic what network
there's called a small world network
characterized by clusters of densely
connected units strong ties and we'll
come back to that loosely connected to
other clusters weak ties and this is
what he describes this is how he says so
here's a command here's a command of
teams here is separate nodes and here's
his team of teams and that looks like a
small world network it may be another
example of a modular hierarchical
network but I'll just say right now I
haven't I haven't worked that all
through I think it does it's not
necessary his point though is again
densely connected no sub groups who are
loosely connected to the center small
world networks though evolved according
to a set of laws that operate in the
natural and the virtual world
McChrystal needed a small world network
to that would work to accomplish a
special specific purpose so he relies on
the twin pillars of shared consciousness
and empowered execution all members of
the network received the same general
and continually updated information
every day a feat that they accomplished
by transforming the daily operations and
intelligence brief into a rich daily
discussion that anyone on any team both
from the special command and from any
other partner government agency could
dial into securely and both listen and
speak the O&I the operations and
intelligence became the neural network
in his terms of the entire team of teams
involving almost 7,000 people engaging
daily for over two hours the entire idea
of the forum completely blows apart the
classic military need to know secrecy
and fostered a culture of radical
sharing 7,000 people for two hours with
you know everybody from from the
operators on the ground to the general
in charge and lots of other agencies so
to maximize both the spread and the
accuracy of the information that all
teams needed to operate effectively he
did need to connect everyone to each
other again creating a complete network
so for communications purposes this is
what
his network needed to look like because
everybody had to hear the same
information it was not only getting the
information it was creating this sense
of joint cognition and shared purpose
you know and and indeed in a complete
network theoretically we know quote the
probability of abdominal action can be
increased to one by simply increasing
the number of nodes meaning the more
nodes you have the more connected they
are the better more likely are to choose
optimum optimal action that's a formal
way of describing what others would call
the wisdom of crowds the more people you
have the more connected they are they
come up with the right response what he
basically did was to overlay this
network for communications purposes on
top of that network for action purposes
and so he got the shared consciousness
but then critically he got the empowered
execution of these teams being able to
work on their own so what he didn't
expect was that this process of
developing a shared consciousness
strengthened his ability to implement
the the principle of empowered execution
empowered and execution means pushing
Authority as far down the chain of
command as possible providing general
guidelines and a shared sense of purpose
and allowing employees at all level or
team members at all levels to exercise
their own judgement shared consciousness
and empowered in empowered execution are
interrelated as McChrystal relates as
team members listened to superiors
debate problems on the oh and I and the
complete network it allowed them to
understand the perspectives of senior
leadership which then quote gave them
the skills and confidence to solve their
own similar problems without the need
for further guidance and clarification
so overall this is a collaboration
Network its tasked to do something very
clear but that in a way where it's not
the way you're doing it is continually
evolving and so what he did was to build
a collaboration network that is Janus
faced that is that time structured like
a social learning network with a clear
with a complete network where everyone's
learning and at other times like a small
nut
Network small world network both the
collective learning and the delegation
are necessary for collaborative action
all right back to our table of contents
here mmm
I'm not sure I'm gonna make this we may
have relatively few questions today
all right so McChrystal's teams whether
operating is a team of teams or as
autonomously we're innovating constantly
but they were innovating as I said in
pursuit of a clear goal the innovation
wasn't the goal the goal was to destroy
al Qaeda in in Iraq but suppose
innovation is the goal that the reason
you assemble a particular group or
community of people is because you need
new products services ideas or solutions
to problems so the problem that you
might think of a how to monitor carbon
emissions how to monitor and report
human rights violations how to curb
illegal fishing how to make
desalinization easier and cheaper these
are all problems that governments
international organizations development
organizations and other participants in
global affairs are actively crackling
with allocating research dollars is the
traditional solution but such dollars
would be much better spent within a
network designed explicitly for
innovation so those networks are the
backbone of an approach to innovation
that is described by its creators as a
new paradigm called open innovation for
those of you who are thinking
open-source I'm going to come back to
this is open innovation in fact open
innovation is referred to as networked
innovation so in the book open
innovation published back in 2003 Henry
Chesbrough distinguishes between
traditional models of closed innovation
where you essentially have an Rd group
in a company or an organization and they
work and the lots of different projects
and ultimately some of those make it
through that's the the closed innovation
as opposed to and
and of course that all proprietary the
company pays for the Rd and expects to
harvest the ideas and the products and
the processes that result open
innovation assumes quote that firms can
and use external ideas as well as
internal ideas and external and internal
paths to market so you do have an
internal R&D base but you've also got
research business intelligence you've
got external technology firms external
venture handling you've got you've got
licensees that spin out lots of
different ways to come up with ideas and
then ultimately get them to market so
open innovation actually turns a firm
into a set of hub nodes and networks
that connect to value in many different
ways and give you a concrete example
companies like Procter & Gamble and Eli
Lilly and government agencies like the
Pentagon outsource many research
problems to an innovation platform
called InnoCentive incentive to innovate
which advertises itself as quote a
global network of millions of problem
solvers so you know Eli Lilly puts up a
problem on the platform and a community
of inventors it's not to the world they
don't put it out on Twitter they put it
out on a designed platform and inventors
from all over the world can solve those
problems and be paid for it so it's open
innovation so that model is an approach
that applies to for-profit companies or
at least to organizations that intend to
capture at least a portion of the value
of the resulting innovation for their
own purposes that's the distinction
between open innovation and open source
open source is much more open-ended and
less structured to cumulative innovation
and I'm going to come back to come to
that too at the end of this discussion
what they do have in common and I'm not
going to elaborate on this at great
length open innovation and open source
what lets you do this is essentially the
power of the link right it is now
possible because we can link to each
other for each of us to specialize in a
narrower area and then link to others
who have complementary
expertise and indeed Jeff Jarvis who
wrote what would Google do starts out by
saying you know the length sort of
basically changes everything because we
know not will no longer have to know
things ourselves and that's essentially
what this model does it says there are
lots of people out there and they have
lots of information and instead of
trying to do it ourselves we will link
to them that division of labor also just
interestingly says that innovation comes
from teams and not from single heroes
it's not the Steve Jobs model although
actually the new Steve Jobs movie says
the Steve Jobs model is not the Steve
Jobs model that it was teams all along
so if you ant analogize with the private
sector an entity like an NGO or an
international organization or a
public-private partnership that seeks to
direct innovation to solve a specific
problem and create value for the world
becomes a network Orchestrator and the
orchestrator has to decide whom to
connect ideally combining deep and wide
ties as well as formal and informal ties
so again this is Mark Granovetter z--
most famous sociological paper ever
which that says you know if you want to
get a job don't ask your friends ask
your acquaintances because deep ties
great you're very close to your friends
that means you all know the same people
and if there were a job somebody would
have found it you want to go to people
you don't know well to your weak ties
because you don't know them as well
you're not as close but they will know
people you don't so the way that the
structure of these networks and this is
again from the business literature is
you want to design an open innovation
network that has a combination of deep
of deep ties and wide ties or weak ties
they call them wide ties and also formal
and informal ties the formal ties of
contract the informal ties of I just
dropped by your lab or I sent you an
email and again we could work that at
the the structures are more carefully
worked out so
again and we'll talk about this a little
more tomorrow these networks don't run
themselves there the literature on open
innovation is now full of how of work on
how you actually manage these and
networks how you create ecosystems but
essentially they are structuring
networks that maximize these different
properties and that combine the value of
in-house work with external work so if
you place this to foreign policy you
should we should be turning to
innovation networks when we have more
open-ended problems to solve but these
problems have to be specific enough the
bigger is not always better so you
should be thinking how to curb illegal
fishing not how to save the oceans you
have to have a quite defined problem
otherwise it won't work
and again you then have to create the
network and orchestrate it and manage it
alright moving on to scale problems so
many global problems are actually scale
problems so take International
Development the introduction of
randomized controlled trials has made it
possible for us to measure the different
approaches to issues like improving
health or combating poverty but even
once we've identified initiatives that
genuinely do make a difference across
multiple contexts how do we replicate
them across millions of villages and
communities alternatively assume when
we're fighting epidemics that a number
of different approaches will work from
bed nets to new treatments and vaccines
how do you align the thousands of
different large and small organizations
groups and/or individuals working on a
particular disease or cluster of health
issues to to coordinate their actions to
maximize their impact and then finally
how do we cumulate the ideas and
knowledge that all these different
players are generating in a way that
builds that builds rather than splinters
scale networks are at least part of the
answer they're particularly valuable for
government policymakers because one of
the great attractions of the chessboard
world is
it's relatively small and it generates
relatively manageable and manageable
initiatives like starting negotiations
are creating a working group group of
governments small initiatives that hold
the potential of big impacts whereas
working in the web world you constantly
feel like okay I did this with a small
number of people with this impact in
this village how do I have the same kind
of impact that I would have if I
negotiated a peace treaty so that's why
so often what we do is a big convening
and we hope that if we bring hundreds of
key players together that somehow
that'll take on a life of its own what
scale networks do is give you tools to
structure and follow up on those
convenings to build networks that can
continue that we can continue the work
so our first category of scale networks
are replication networks
so think about Alcoholics Anonymous aaaa
no one's in charge there is no central
office for a a in fact Ori Brafman and
rod Beckstrom point to a a as the
quintessential example of a
decentralized starfish organization in
their book just to get you away from
that boring gray slide we'll look at
this one for a minute the starfish and
the spider spider organizations are
centralized well then we'll actually
have a spider on the cover wet with a
leader in charge and a headquarters that
functions as a central nervous system
for the entire organization think take
kill the spiders head you got a problem
a successful attack will destroy it will
decapitate it and that's to sort destroy
it starfish organizations have no one in
charge no permanent location or central
headquarters no clear division of roles
autonomous decentralized units that can
be individually destroyed without
harming the entire organization and the
distribute knowledge and power
throughout the organization so you know
you cut off a starfish his arm nothing
happens and so actually they describe
how actual industries have evolved in
this direction and this is the music
industry where you know the recording
industry was highly centralized
you had Napster but Napster was
centralized enough that the government
could take it out then they went to a
bunch of things that I don't actually
use but I am going to believe them some
of you probably know it is now
completely decentralized in the way that
we get music it is no longer possible to
actually stop the spreading of music no
there's no Center to stop so that's a
starfish organization so what's most
interesting for our purposes about
starfish organizations is the way that
information spreads and groups replicate
each other so in the a in AAA
or more recently TEDx if any of you
follow TED Talks very similar TEDx has
taken off right and Ted has ideas we're
spreading they have two big conferences
every year they created TEDx which
supports independent organizers who want
to have a TED type conference it started
in 2009 its generated 10,000 events with
almost 50,000 people with held all over
the world with with many more talks both
AAA and TEDx have the same structures
what I call this replication Network
it's a template that anyone can follow
so there is no owner there's no one in
charge
it allows everyone to be in charge you
can set up an AAA
group if and of alcoholics or anyone
else in your neighborhood
or you can create a TEDx network and
there are other examples so replicate
replication networks combine the power
of decentralization and the empowerment
of local with the empowerment of local
ownership and customization they're more
than just the viral spread of a meme
across social media they offer a prize a
resource and a product that people need
and want at the same time many relies
strongly once again on the sort of
social cure the idea that you have a
peer group in in a a that's a peer group
for positive pressure to stay sober in
something like TEDx
that's actually what makes it go is just
that it's cool right they are selling
the the attractiveness of being cool and
in fact in in a number of authors have
described the way at poor these group
that overthrew Milosevic in Serbia
developed a mode of revolution that
relied on as she as people would say
cool t-shirts and and essentially making
revolution cool it was not about common
overthrow the government it was like
this is a very cool group to hang out
with Peter Ackerman who is a real estate
magnate took the odd pour method and
created an institute for non-violent
conflict that essentially said here's
the template and here's how it can
replicate and it replicated from Serbia
a to Tunisia to Georgia or Serbia to
Georgia to Tunisia to Egypt to other
places so there's we can take this idea
of a template that has a certain kind of
Attraction either that is cool or that
it's helpful or whatever it is and then
allow any group to adopt that template
and that model will then replicate
throughout far and wide so then move
right back to them alright so we've
talked about replication networks let's
think about now coordination networks
and cumulation networks those are
essentially those are both very they're
networks that rely on a vast division of
labor coordination networks parcel out
tasks and cumulation networks gather in
information and I'm going to we're
almost out of time so I'm gonna shorten
that a bit so the best example of a
gathering in coordination network is the
Global Alliance for vaccines and
immunization or Gavi many small
organizations around the world and a
number of larger ones have been working
on vaccinations and vaccination and
immunization for
decades Gavi was a game-changer it
brought together the Gates Foundation
the World Health Organization UNICEF and
the World Bank to work with developed
and developing country governments civil
society organizations pharmaceutical
companies and both developed and
developing countries research and
technical institutes around the world
each member of the network or each
category of members has a specific role
to play from providing funding and
research to guaranteeing markets for new
vaccines to delivering vaccines on the
ground to the people who need them scale
makes the network work you you
accumulate the demand from multiple
countries that creates a market for
vaccines against poor country infectious
diseases as not normally a market and
but so too does the division of labor so
the fact that it's big makes it work and
the fact that it's big and specialized
makes it work that's so that's a
coordination that work that gathers that
you know tasks out different kinds of
work you can do the same thing in a more
specific way you can take tasks that
need to be done and parcel them out like
Amazon's Mechanical Turk same kind of
idea all of those networks are
effectively it should not be the end of
the sideshow all right well see yes
sorry all of those networks are
effectively star networks they have a
very clear center some of their some of
the other links are connected but you
don't want everybody connected for the
reasons I said before that that creates
too much information what makes those
networks work is again what happens at
the center and that's what I'm going to
talk about tomorrow in terms of
leadership the final kind of replication
network is accumulation Network where
it's again a star network but you're
gathering in information and this is the
open source model and I don't have to go
into great detail here think Wikipedia
right that's what accumulation network
is it takes knowledge or code if we want
to talk about Linux it allows anybody
to contribute that's the great value of
the star Network but here's what makes
it work this is the one place you'll
hear me talk about hierarchies because
to make accumulation network work you
actually have to have some hierarchy at
the center if it were just everybody
editing Wikipedia entries who would ever
know what you could trust and believe me
as a person who's had my own entry
edited periodically there needs to be
some curation some vetting some
enforcing of community norms and that
doesn't happen just through a network
that happens through an old-fashioned
hierarchy it's a small one there are
only about 50 people at the center of
Wikipedia but to make it really work
well with a mass audience you need a
hierarchy this is not true with Linux
but Linux is a very specialized
cumulation network of the the the group
of of programmers so three kinds of
scale networks how to get a particular
template that works to replicate
seemingly magically seemingly on its own
the way various groups are now
replicating coordination networks where
you have lots and lots of groups and
they're all working on the same thing
but their work is not coordinated and
cumulation networks where you have an
astonishing amount of knowledge about a
particular subject from many different
people but you need to create a
structure for how to actually accumulate
that and curate it all right so
resilience tasks and scale networks are
the tools that are necessary to
formulate and implement a strategy of
connection I would say strategies of
connection they're all ways of using
human and institutional connections to
accomplish specific strategic purposes
creating orchestrating and managing them
will require more than understanding the
conceptual framework and the specific
structures and processes necessary to
make them work building networks is a
new way of exercising power it will also
require new tools of
policymaking itself and it will
advantage different kinds of leaders the
subject of our lecture tomorrow is
policy power and leadership in a
networked world thank you very much all
right well there's like ten minutes for
questions I think maybe I promised
tomorrow's it's a great question and
there is an answer although it always
sounds easier you know when you're not
not in government and it's not an
immediate answer but we do actually I
think I said this yesterday but I can't
remember so if I did just let me say it
again we know quite a bit about a lot of
these people who are going to Syria to
fight we know I was saying that new
America has a database of over 375 of
these people whom we have called just
from open news sources but digging very
deeply we there's a there 1500 total or
at least that's what's estimated and so
we've looked at you know quote getting
close to a third of them they are it's
remarkable
there's the profile there's generally a
family connection so if your uncle is
doing jihad you go do jihad there are
they are they're young and they are
increasingly women and there are other
attributes so what you do here is
exactly to create you figure out the
ways
you disrupt their peer groups
effectively you identify where the the
the a lot of these are particular
schools or mosques where there's a
highest concentration but you go beyond
that you actually map okay we know these
families have been involved we know that
these families are connected to other
families you disrupt those networks but
you create and this is critical you
create positive alternatives and once
that starts working you replicate that
through all the countries these 375
people have come from over 25 countries
and so you you the but this these are
long-term networks there are lots of
programs on you know how you
rehabilitate former jihadists how you
work with with and it's very similar to
gang members this is not limited to one
so we have solutions that work what we
don't have is the mapping of the network
and the profiles that allow us to look
at how do we both did as I said disrupt
the existing networks and create
alternative peer networks but this is
exactly where the so the sort of joined
the club and the creation of tight-knit
groups can really make a difference
other questions yes and I actually did
find those critical points and
was able to reconcile the surgeons and
do the things I was read in a book
somewhere but the hardest part I found
was eventually the network did you find
yourself in is inadequate to solve the
complex problems so in other words
identify the network in my area domain
but then eventually the problem I'm
trying to solve the evolves into such a
large problem that the network is so
expensive it goes into Pakistan because
so far outside your control and I just
wondered is it is it my being felt
listen to say are there complex problems
that don't have solutions and that you
maybe you increase your knowledge but
it's almost impossible to that's a great
question I will write it down this is
where I out of here try yeah so I guess
I I mean yes we are facing wicked
problems we know that and you know I'd
be foolhardy to stand up and say I've
got nine a little the kinds of networks
and one that'll fix everything I would
say a couple of things I'd say one
understanding it that way also can mean
we need to be developing network
disruption tools right so the extent you
know that we it and we're thinking about
in other words how do you take what is a
an overly expansive problem and try to
localize it and but again thinking about
and I mean I know the answer that
question yes we should rather than going
after the mint and Pakistan not in
Afghanistan as long as we were only
attacking people in Afghanistan it was
never gonna work but partly I would say
training policymakers to think in these
terms would give them a very different
understanding that this is a fool's
errand as long as we're is because it's
one network and we're fighting it in one
place and that that doesn't work I think
the other the other thing I would say
and we don't know and this is why I
focus on network Theory not complexity
theory because I have no idea how to
turn complexity theory into a set of
tools because it essentially says you
connect enough people in the right way
and good things start happening
and oh but I would say that I think if
we adopt these networked approaches more
systematically in more places you may
indeed start to find bigger positive
networks that can counter the bigger
negative networks but I cannot say with
any certainty that it I don't think
that's a question of exactly whom you
connect I think it's a question of
getting enough of the positive elements
and then having having emergence happen
and but honestly in working out the book
I will be working much more deeply in
those areas of theory what I've found
thus far as I said is it's great at
describing but as a policymaker it is
like okay get good people together but
thanks for the question we should
probably